so what exactly makes a minimalist
smartphone I've heard of some people say
things like well if you're really a
minimalist you wouldn't have a
smartphone to begin with but minimalism
is about adding things that bring value
to your life and removing what excess
means for you and that's unique to your
life and your needs this is by no means
the right way to use a smartphone but
it's the way that I use it in a way that
adds value to my life hey guys I'm yesi
and today I'm going to show you what's
on my minimalist iPhone I will share
tips that help me to keep my phone
minimal organized and decluttered as
well as some hacks that help me to make
adopting and sticking to more positive
habits much easier this way I can use
technology in a way that can improve my
life rather than create addictive phone
habits but so as not to drag this video
out I will create a separate video on
tons of tips that help me to increase
productivity and minimize distractions
when using a smartphone so be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on that
video or any of my other videos on
minimalism and living life more fully
with less the iPhone that I have is the
iPhone 12 Pro Max in Gold I absolutely
love this this thing I use it to film
the majority of my b-roll shots because
it films in 4k in the past I used to
love cases with funky designs and
patterns on them and I always found that
I kept wanting to change them out for
new Styles all the time
for the past couple of years I have used
OtterBox the one that I have is symmetry
and stardust this for me is the perfect
mix between durability and simplicity
but with a little bit of Sparkle between
this and my glass screen protector I am
able to keep my phone safe but also
maintain a Sleek look that isn't too
bulky or attention grabbing I have also
dropped my phone numerous times so a
durable screen protector is a must for
me I will link both of these in the
description box below in case you want
to check them out and now on to what is
actually on the phone itself my lock
screen is a short reminder of the way
that I want to live my life and the
person that I aim to be nothing super
fancy here nothing too stimulating or
distracting welcome to my main screen
the background is a landscape photo of
the Tennessee mountains and I
specifically chose this photo because it
doesn't have a whole lot of colors it's
not too distracting and it doesn't have
too much going on it's a Serene image
that I don't change out and swap for my
kids photos or photos all the time this
basically stays the same so for me is a
perfect way to minimize distractions
without using a Blanche solid color as
you can see I keep only the basics on my
main screen on the bottom I have the
most used apps calls messages internet
and of course my Google Calendar which I
am obsessed about for Life admin but
keeping my main screen clear of any
other apps makes it much more organized
so don't have to sift through anything
to find the ones that I use the most
sliding to the left of my phone
alternates to different photos
throughout the day and it allows for a
quick weather check greetings from
Atlanta by the way and let me know in
the comments where are you watching from
I typically use Google Calendar to
organize my day-to-day and keep up with
important dates and birthdays but when I
want to make sure something absolutely
gets done I set an alarm so right at the
top left I have my alarm app I use the
heck out of my alarms if I'm cooking
dinner and I just remember that I need
to send a package in the mail I'll tell
Siri and I also use the Siri function to
schedule events on my Google Calendar
and I love doing this because I don't
have to be in front of my phone and
physically in front of the screen in
order to get something done for me the
more hands off I can be with technology
the better and by the way if this video
is being helpful so far please give it a
thumbs up so I'll know to make more
videos like these alright so moving on
to the next page this is where I keep
the rest of my apps I organize my apps
by type and purpose so the top three row
are for education and entertainment the
next three are for education and
organization and then the bottom three
are all for YouTube and we'll talk about
the groups later hoopla is the app that
I use to obtain free ebooks and
audiobooks from my local library a
similar version is the Libby app you can
go to your local library and find out if
they have such an app I love this app
because it allows me to take mundane
tasks like driving to work or washing
the dishes and it gives me an
opportunity to learn something but I
also use the audible app because
unfortunately my library does not have
many of the newer books available
Audible has an incredible selection of
over 180 000 titles in Originals
audiobooks and podcasts to choose from
either through subscription or you can
purchase them to keep such as my kids
favorite number songs for your own free
30-day trial as well as a free audiobook
you can use my affiliate link down in
the description box below you can cancel
at any time but using this link helps
support my channel so thank you in
advance and let me know what book you
end up choosing I'm always on the hunt
for a good book recommendation okay so
back to my apps on the sides I have
three different categories or groups my
utility group is basically my junk
drawer for my phone I've deleted most of
the apps that come with the iPhone when
you first get it and only kept the
necessary ones so for me this is where I
keep the necessary but rarely used apps
the middle is where I keep our home
finance apps such as banking our
security cameras and where I manage our
lifx smart bulbs to set schedules for
them or automatically dim in the
evenings and turn it off at a specific
time it's also where I manage our smart
thermostat and I talk about these two in
my video how to wake up at 5am feeling
glorious because they're a huge help to
me in creating better sleep habits
setting me up for a more productive day
and the rest are for grocery stores and
gas stations that give loyalty discounts
and coupons the bottom group is strictly
for my nursing job so that I can
securely sign documents message doctors
as well as send faxes for free right
through my phone with easyfax and so now
I'll quickly guide you through the rest
of my apps I use Spotify to listen to
music because I can create playlists so
classical music when I'm trying to focus
for example or upbeat music when I'm
working out I use the free version and I
can also use Siri to tell it to start a
playlist or stop a playlist or even skip
a song I'll be honest I rarely use the
podcast app because 99 of the time I am
either listening to music or listening
to audiobooks and embarrassingly I'm
still trying to learn how the heck it
even works but I would love to have a
podcast someday so that you can have the
option of hearing my content rather than
having to watch it so it's really there
just as something that I'm trying to
learn more about and that I want to do
in the future Duolingo is an adorable
app that makes learning foreign
languages fun and effortless it has
short lessons that give you reminders
when you have missed a lesson it's
interactive and it has a free version
the notes app is where I jot down my
video ideas to-do's that aren't urgent
or recipes that turn out well YouTube
studio is basically what I use to answer
comments or make any changes to my
videos of course you're familiar with
the new YouTube app but canva is
something that I'm recently
experimenting with you can use it to
make invitations for web design
presentations social media posts to make
collages Flyers the possibilities are
endless I used it to create my first
post on YouTube and I'm having a lot of
fun experimenting with it and in the
words of Bugs Bunny That's all folks I
hope this video has been helpful for you
if so please give it a thumbs up and
subscribe so you won't miss when I post
a new video and feel free to let me know
any video recommendations you have or
that you would like to see in the future
I thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you in the next one bye for now
foreign